I'm Pico aya and I'm a travel writer
I've been traveling the world and
writing about my travels since 1986 I've
written 15 books and more than a
thousand articles and I've been talking
and traveling with the 14th Dalai Lama
for 45 years over the years I've
developed some tips for how to become a
better traveler here they are tip number
one walk walk and walk and walk
letting a place introduce itself to you
walking allows me to reflect while I'm
observing it's a human pace Singapore is
a perfect place to walk and to see
cultures of East and West come together
in always surprising words tip number
two observe I travel in order to wake up
to open my eyes so when I'm in a new
place I want to see everything around me
a hotel is a city in miniature there are
short stories taking place in every room
and on every corridor I love to observe
dramas unfolding around me will this be
tragedy or comedy or simple romance
he keeps twirling his straw what's that
toss of the hair mean what do they say
tip number three reflect at the end of a
busy day go to a quiet place to collect
your thoughts and make sense of
everything you've seen reflection is how
you turn the sites you've seen into
insights it's how you turn experience
into meaning walking and observing how
you gather the ingredients of your
travel reflection is how you turn them
into a meal if you follow these tips
you'll return home a different person
all the great travel books are love
stories that's why the best trips like
love stories never really end
[Music]